Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
I’m KP and in this lesson, we’ll learn
about selection using the protein carbonic
anhydrase.
Carbon dioxide is a waste product produced
by our cells.
Only a small percentage of this gas dissolves
directly in blood plasma, some is carried
by hemoglobin, but about 70% of it is reacted
by carbonic anhydrase and carried to the lungs
as water-soluble bicarbonate ions.
In the lungs, carbonic anhydrase reverses
the reaction, remaking carbon dioxide, which
we breathe out.
In lesson 1, we learned to load the biological
unit of macromolecules.
File, get PDB, type 3UYN, set the assembly
to 1, and click download.
Here’s carbonic anhydrase!
Display the sequence and we’re ready to
model.
From the RCSB page, we can access the manuscript
describing this structure.
Some manuscripts are behind a paywall, but
this is where I found one that gave numbers
for the important amino acids in this lesson’s
structure.
Real quick, some terminology.
An enzyme is a protein that performs a chemical
reaction, making or breaking covalent bonds.
The active site is the part of an enzyme where
a chemical reaction takes place, and it is
made up of amino acids.
When we refer to amino acids in a protein,
we often call them residues.
Back to business!
We’re going to create and save separate
selections for zinc, the active site residues,
and the water molecules that interact with
the active site.
Scrolling through our sequence, we have the
amino acid one-letter codes, a zinc ion, and
waters.
Click on zinc, either in the sequence or by
clicking on the gray sphere on the structure
in the structure viewer window.
The letters sele come up in the names panel.
Click A next to them and choose “rename
selection.”
In the upper left-hand side of the structure
viewer window, a prompt comes up.
Delete the letters SELE and type a new name.
I’ll call this “zinc”.
Now, very important, click somewhere in the
blank space in structure viewer window to
clear the selection, otherwise the next object
you click on will be added to the zinc selection.
Now, let’s select the amino acid residues
that make up carbonic anhydrase’s active
site.
Using the sequence display, scroll back to
the amino acids.
I’ll put the list of amino acids we need
on screen.
First, we’re looking for residue 5.
Notice that residue 6 is labeled, so residue
5 is this tryptophan just to the left of it.
Click on it to select.
Next we need residue 7.
Then N62—be careful, there’s another N,
asparagine, right next to it, so be sure you
select the correct one.
K64 next, then H67.
Now, H94: 91-2-3-4.
Next up is H96.
And let’s stop here at histidine 119.
If it makes it easier for you, you can use
the display dropdown menu to change the sequence
mode to show three-letter codes.
I don’t, because I like the way I can see
breaks in the sequence with the one-letter
codes to easily identify different protein
chains and ligands.
Notice in the object panel, the letters sele
have popped up again.
Rename this to “active”.
A button, rename.
Delete sele and type “active”.
Click in the blank space of the structure
viewer window to clear the selection.
But, oh no, we forgot two residues!
No problem, just click on active again in
the names panel to select it.
With this selected, we can add the missing
residues.
Find threonine 199 and 200 in the sequence
and click on them.
Added!
Click in the blank space.
Active site selection complete.
Selecting active site residues with the command
line is way faster.
Here’s the command on screen—you can pause
if you’re interested.
The different ways we represent structures
are called renderings.
In PyMOL, the protein is shown as a cartoon
rendering by default.
It makes sense to show our active site residues
in a way that lets us see the atoms, though,
since they’ll interact with the reactants
as the chemical reaction takes place.
Add stick rendering to show the active site
residues.
Next to active in the names panel, click S
for show, and select “sticks”.
What PyMOL is doing is layering representations
on top of each other.
Now let’s see what “show as” does.
Active, S, show as, sticks.
Woah, parts of the protein cartoon get chopped
out!
Let’s not do that.
Click S next to active and add the cartoon
back in.
Let’s zoom in on the active site.
Names panel, active, A, zoom.
Notice how parts of the structure fade—some
clipping has been applied.
Check out video 1 for a description of clipping
and how to adjust it.
PyMOL can automatically find the interactions
that polar atoms make.
Find active in the names panel.
Click A, find, polar contacts, to any atoms.
Notice yellow dotted lines show the interactions.
Let’s do the same for zinc.
A, find, polar contacts, to any atoms.
Now we have two different sets of contacts
in the names panel.
Notice some water molecules have interactions
with the active site amino acid residues and
zinc.
Let’s select them by clicking on them in
the structure.
Rotate and zoom as needed to find them all.
Now, save this selection.
A, rename, delete sele, and let’s call this
active water.
Now, we’ll hide the rest of the water in
the structure.
Next to 3UYN, click the hide button, H, waters.
But we do want to show waters in the active
site.
Next to active water, S, spheres.
This applies a rendering called spacefill.
But the waters look huge and might obstruct
parts of the active site.
Let’s resize them using a preset PyMOL has
built in.
Next to active_water, A, preset, ball and
stick.
Ah, that’s much better.
The interactions look bad because some are
look like they’re going to nowhere.
They’re actually contacting residues or
waters we haven’t shown.
I’ll show you how to fix that in an episode
on measurement, but for now let’s just turn
them off by deselecting them in the names
panel.
When we display amino acids as sticks, PyMOL
shows the atoms that make up both the backbone
and side chain.
The backbone atoms connect the groups that
form new covalent bonds when the protein is
made.
The side chain is the variable group—the
R group on that specific amino acid.
We can show or hide each of these separately.
So, next to active, select H, main chain.
To add it back: show, main chain, sticks.
We’ve done a ton of work!
Control S to save this PyMOL session to your
computer—we’ll use it in Lesson 3.
Hope to see you next time!